[Music]
What happened to us today is that the army entered in
its turn. I was in my shop
normally and they entered the shop and asked to search the shop.
How did the young men who worked for me
in the shop look and smell me personally? We went outside
after we went outside with our stomachs on the ground. We were
pulled out at  Al-Jabbat told
the young men who are with me to go. I
want to use you as a human shield. It is forbidden
for young men to be stoned, and you want to walk in front of me. This is what happened to me and
we were dragged to the middle of the country.
[Music]
Of course [
Music] [
Music]
Youth. And the martyr Hadmah and the martyr Taha
Muhammadb.
Great is the greatest. God is the greatest
[Music]
[Applause]
God